all right jade
hi jade where'd you grow up who are you
from originally um born and raised in
lincoln nebraska
wow tell me about that
um well i grew up
pretty white trash um
i grew my old house was built on a dump
from the 1800s
and i lived next to the trailer parks
um
yeah was your family like
um at first when i was young it was like
super cool you know i grew up pretty
normal
activities but turns out
mental illness runs in the family
and my parents are
avid drug users and they have been most
of my life
so how'd that affect your childhood
well
when i was younger my parents like my
father worked
and
i don't know things were normal until
like eight and then the opioid
pandemic crisis hit my home and my dad
would like doctor shop and
get really [ __ ] up and they stopped
kind of
paying attention
and they sold a bunch of things and we
were really poor
and my dad lost his job well he didn't
lose it but he ended up
getting on
like welfare because he couldn't work
anymore so the government just paid us
ever since
my mom never had a job
and i had no idea until i got older but
she was dope sick a lot of the time and
it was just really chaotic not having
money
and having drug users for
parents how would you describe your
childhood
um
sad it was really sad i got picked on a
lot i didn't know i was super poor until
i was older
which kind of sucked
um
i was just like a weird kid
and
i don't know like my parents didn't care
like as long as we looked good on the
outside it didn't really matter
how things were at home like my
grandmother always bought us clothes and
took us
me and my half brother like shopping so
we looked good
but it was always really bad
um
you know it wasn't like just oh my
parents are smoking weed and drinking it
was like
my dad's doing oxies and my mom's
sharing them
and my parents would like go on little
weekend vacations and like go do meth
in motels
and [ __ ] like that and leave me
in not the best care
so it sounds like a lot of neglect
there was a lot and a lot of emotional
neglect and stuff like that um it's not
like they ever hit me or abused me or
anything like that but
they just didn't
like they didn't even teach me how to
tie my shoes like that's something i
learned how to do when i was in fourth
grade like i taught myself a lot of
things because they just didn't care to
well it's not that they didn't care they
just couldn't
because they were in their own problems
finish high school
absolutely i did
and then i did some college but
you know life's hard when you don't have
a
foundation so you kind of have to make
one for yourself
you needed to support yourself i did
really i did um i started hustling when
i was like 13
um i just like knew a bunch of drug
dealers and they would like set me up
and i would just go sell drugs to like
all of my peers i was always just like a
bad little kid
after um you know middle school
because i was like [ __ ] it you know i
needed to make money it's not like my
parents cared the school sure as [ __ ]
did not care
or they would have stepped in a lot
sooner you know what i mean
you feel like the the lack of discipline
or the freedom that
your
childhood your your parents gave you was
the reason that you
took the sex work
um
i think i took to sex work because i was
always intrigued like i grew up and my
aunt was always one of my big role
models and she was like a playboy golfer
or
she would work events as a model and
like sexuality was always just like an
open
big thing at a young age so i was like
she looks like she's having a lot of fun
and she's pretty and she lives a good
life i was like that's exactly what i
want for myself and like
you know my era growing up because i'm
26 now like britney spears was a huge
thing christina aguilera like lots of
sexuality
on the tv and i was like
me too but i was an ugly kid so it like
took a while for me to be comfortable
and confident to do it
when did you start and how did you start
um i started when i was 20 years old i
ended up quitting my job i was working
overnights at a village inn
so i was working like 12 hour shifts
just to make like 200
and i knew i was going through like a
manic panic episode or something because
i shaved my head recently like i always
wanted to shave my head so i shaved my
head quit my [ __ ] job and i was like
you know what i know a couple strippers
i was like let me
just get a hold of him so i walked out
of my job the next day
i called a club and i went and i
auditioned and then i spent my last two
hundred dollars on
shoes a wig
and just like some lingerie
you started making money i did my first
night i made like
500 and my second night was valentine's
day and i walked out with like 800. so i
made over a thousand dollars in like two
days and i was like
okay i could do this there's no turning
back after that no but it was like
it was super easy for me
like i always
wanted to be desired because i was an
ugly kid and i always had like movement
and flow like i was double jointed and i
was just like had a natural rhythm
and so it kind of just fit especially
being like a degenerate like that's
where they go and especially in nebraska
like everything's run down there's like
not a super nice strip club they're like
on the side of a highway and like a
warehouse type [ __ ] that's kind of where
they are everywhere though yeah like
they are run down but
farmers money it's good [ __ ]
and you you've tried other types of sex
work as well
um yeah i would say like later on
in my journey like i got more
comfortable like my first five years i
was strictly like a stripper and i
couldn't believe that people were like
doing more for money
and like people had sugar daddies i was
like so disgusted and naive when i was
young
and then i started like traveling and i
met so many women that i idolized just
because
they're the ones making the most money
and you learn things from them and you
learn that like
having a sugar daddy makes you
consistent money
more often than just finding random
people at the strip club
and then you move on from that and you
go to different regions and you're like
oh [ __ ]
this is a brothel
and you're like am i gonna do this or am
i not gonna do this
and then somebody puts like
a couple thousand in your face for the
first time and you're like
oh you're gonna pay me that
much for like an hour of my time
in a club i was like okay
so i did it i started and it was weird
like the first time i did it i was like
in miami i was with a couple
and a cuban girl and she's like hey
we want you to join us for our vip and i
was like okay cool like
standard women usually like me i
figured that out
and so i go back and she's like just
entertain the wife and i look over and
husband is [ __ ]
the other girl and i'm like
oh we do that here
and so that was my first like experience
and like nobody stopped it like there's
cameras in the room but like some of
them don't even record a lot of strip
clubs will have this going on they know
exactly what's going on you just pay
them their cut and they're good but the
girls that i've interviewed a lot of
them will tell me well i don't do that
oh no absolutely i absolutely do that
i mean it's just like it's part of it
you know if you're gonna really be in
sex work
then you gotta own it
because there's no point
in
being ashamed of it like
who else is getting paid thousands of
dollars for 30 minutes you know what i
mean you just have to have like the
class and the scale like the
the height you hold yourself at is the
standard you're gonna be
presented at
so it's like a whole
spiel like you don't just become a good
sex worker overnight
it takes a really long time and i know
women in their 30s who are doing the
best they've ever done
and making the easiest money they've
ever made probably get wiser as they go
yeah and you just have to like
keep yourself
away from certain groups of people
because it will suck you in like drugs
are a huge thing like my first year of
stripping i put myself through rehab
because i just like i finally made
enough money and i realized i was going
down a really bad path and i didn't
didn't want to do that it seems like
drugs will derail
everything even in a stripper's career
oh yeah and they're so common because
who goes to a strip club drug dealers
why because people want drugs there it's
like it's own
underground
nightlife that people just
look over they're like oh it's a
bachelor party like let's go to the
strip club it's like no this is real
life for a lot of people
what's the secret to
finding and keeping a sugar daddy
okay well first off you cannot be
yourself well you can at some point you
choose what you want to show somebody
and
first off not any guy can be a good
sugar daddy right oh no they have to
like prove it so first off you like
maybe in the club or they have like
websites for it but that's a little iffy
so like you find a good one in the club
usually an older gentleman you always
look for people in like suits or maybe
you go to the awkward guy because
he just doesn't
get that interaction that he wants with
the lady
and so you provide that like when you
have a sugar daddy you need to
give them what they're seeking and not
not every time is it sex like some
people are just emotionally
like
they lack that connection and they just
want to be seen and heard
and maybe cuddled
so
you just sought out a weird guy or a
rich looking guy and you sit down and
you talk to them about their life do you
drop hints about the fact that you can't
pay your rent this month or things like
that no it's never that because they
know
they know i'm highly sought after so
they want to maybe
treat me better than anyone else does so
i treat them better
and it's
i don't know it's kind of like a game
like you
i think if you you have to know
high-class things and you have to be
very knowledgeable to relate to these
men
like
i don't know some are farmers but others
are
you know
lawyers or they do
crypto i had to learn all about crypto
and bitcoin and all this other [ __ ] when
it came out so i could talk
to sugar daddies because i had no idea
or nfts oh that was a terrible time to
be in the strip club i hated hearing
about nfts all the time and
cryptocurrency
but you have to sit there and you have
to be involved and you have to actually
pick up on things so you you worked
mostly in
nebraska early on in your career i
stripped in nebraska
for
five years
no i'm lying probably
i started traveling after three
and then i went to like
north dakota and then texas
um arizona but some places you have to
have licenses so you have to like
look into it and look it up before you
go you can't just show up yeah because
in some places they do like background
checks and they see if you have a record
of felonies or prostitution because a
lot of clubs won't hire you
if you have that on your record
where do you live now
i live in south florida but i have spent
the summer in nebraska because i'm
moving back there you're gonna go back
to nebraska [ __ ] yes after southern
florida yeah it's just like i don't know
i feel like when you stay too long
in one place like i don't want to push
my career longer than it needs to go
down there
it's very fast pace and it's
i'm not going to lie like stripping up
north is way easier money and people are
way more respectful
like down south it's a lot of
bbls and
people do a lot more for a lot less
and if again you hold yourself to that
standard it's just not worth it
the midwest is all
less
not as fast
it's not as fast paced it's really like
chill
and farmers are out there so there's
seasons everywhere so it's good to
travel during seasons like go way up
north during pheasant season or tax
season because
the amount of men there is to women and
even beautiful like extravagant women is
insane
so what do they do they come and spend
their money
and you don't even have to you know
suck their dick or anything and get a
little bag are you saying there's a lot
of girls like there aren't many girls
like you in nebraska
no there is
and they're some of my dearest friends
and
i've never found women like them so it's
good to keep you know your family and
people close
how does how does this lifestyle affect
you emotionally
um so
ever since i put myself in rehab at like
20 years old i've always consistently
had a therapist i've always made sure
that i'm emotionally okay even from a
younger age i do have a big disconnect
because of my mental illnesses so
stripping is not for everyone but
it's like a character so if you can
disassociate from your normal person in
your real life then you're gonna do
better in stripping you compartmentalize
it yeah so i could be having the worst
day and i'll be like [ __ ] it i'm gonna
go to work and i'm gonna make like 800
or so dollars and
i'm probably gonna feel better as myself
if i do that
because i mean
being sad and poor isn't as fun as being
sad and rich
what are your uh what does your
therapist think of
um
it's so crazy to me because i've had a
couple different therapists so whenever
i move regions or anything like that i
just switch it up
my therapists tell me i'm really smart
and my therapist have actually because
i've had drug issues and i've been
honest about them and i'm like hey like
i'm taking
benzos
to feel better and get through my work
day
and they're like well you can't just
stop
you can't just stop
so they'll know about my drug use
they'll know about my money because i
always pay them cash too
and they're like well if you don't go to
work you can't pay your bills and i'm
like you're right so i need to
come to you to handle all my emotional
[ __ ]
so i can be my best self
and do
what i have to do
when you say mental illness runs in your
family so how has it affected you
are you bipolar um i'm diagnosed bipolar
um manic
depressive anxiety you know just a bunch
of
things ptsd
but
i grew up and my father was very
my father was very much so bipolar my
mom
is just like not there
and so
i don't know
watching them
be who they are
and develop over time
has made me probably put myself in
overdrive so i don't end up that way
and i feel like that's why i'm
constantly
learning and pushing myself to be better
because i do i still support them
sometimes and give them money even
though they kind of suck
but it's like that's my family and to be
the one to break
the generational curses and things like
that
like that's a responsibility so
i took that on
do you have friends
i do i have great friends it's great
it's important right yeah and i always
keep so they say
the five people you keep around in your
closest circle reflects who you are
so
all of my friends go to like therapy or
have families and are
strong women too
or men
what have you learned about men from
doing all this
these different forms of sex where you
also are on only fans too right i am on
only fans um i have learned
this is probably going to ruin my career
but i have learned that if you can make
yourself to what they want they'll give
you exactly what you want
which is shitty but
men are really easy to figure out
like you just have to pay attention to
mannerisms and the things they say and
make them feel good
and it's like
you'll get
what you want
i'm not saying they're easy i've met a
lot of brilliant smart men that have
vices and i know the strip club or
paying for my port online
or taking me out to dinner and it's like
a vice and it's a little high for them
so
i'll be their
drug of choice i don't care
is it does it
impact your self-worth being treated
like a like an object
i would say i spent so much of my life
being objectified
from a young age
to it i am so it's like
am i gonna
be sad about it or am i going to use it
to my advantage
because i don't really detain my
self-worth to
what
i've had to do to get to where i am
because i am so smart and i am so
you know i don't want to say i'm
different than a lot of sex workers
because i'm not like we're all when
we're all in the same building like the
girl who's like a nick for 40 dollars
i'm the same as her she's my mutual like
we're in the same building i can't think
i'm better than her but when i leave and
i take care of myself the way i do
that's
where my self-worth is
have you been in love before
once
once and it was terrible
holy i am 26.
do you see love
as a transactional
interaction
no
but i do you're offering a man
you're a female attractiveness your
sexuality and he's
providing
some security financial security i would
say
the one time i was in love was with an
addict
and i spent two years doing that and it
was definitely
a product of my daddy issues and my
childhood and i understood that
and so i don't date or anything like
that and i know that when i want to
settle down i want to have a partner and
i do not want monogamy monogamy was a
thing created a long time ago by people
who want to do marriage and taxes and
all of that it's just not super
realistic to be with somebody and be
like you only advice for me it's all
about me
you can't have
feelings
for other people or do what you want
but marriage is great for taxes and like
paperwork it's good on paper but it's
not super realistic especially in this
day and age when you have things like
only fans strip clubs and like sex sells
a lot of people are in sex work now more
than ever
yeah it seems like only fans is very
popular especially after the pandemic
because nobody could go outside and
people are like
maybe i can sell pictures of my feet and
pay my rent
do you believe in karma
absolutely
how does karma play out in your
life
um i would say i get very lucky i don't
know what i did
um
and i always just try to make the right
decision you seem very positive
you have to be no you don't i mean you
don't have a lot of people aren't i mean
i would say i'm very positive but i'm
very rational um i can be very
pessimistic and critical about a lot of
things i don't agree with everyone and
i'm very opinionated because i read a
lot i'm a know-it-all that's not for
everyone but
it's just kind of what i go by and
there's like things like i'm spiritual
so obviously i believe in like
you know karma or the energy you give is
the energy you're gonna receive so i
don't believe in like gossiping or being
you know i live by my standard of rules
and i never
am like down on other people or bring
them down
it builds up your self-esteem i assume
no it's just
to be a good person
it's not being a stripper
being an object of so many men
see what's weird though is like
a lot of my clientele is couples or even
women is that right yeah i don't know
why or how i guess i give off a big
lesbian vibe perhaps uh
but
yeah no and it doesn't because i was
ugly for a really long time so i'm super
humbled like i used to get beat up for
being too skinny
because i was malnourished or
just having short hair i wore headgear
people would bark at me in the hallways
i was re i did not peak until
my 20s which i'm very thankful for
because anyone who peaked in high school
is probably not peaking now you know
what i mean
so i also feel like the older you get
the wiser you are the more knowledge and
beauty you have
so it's like not about looks it's about
i don't know
what you are inside reflects on the
outside
so maybe i happen to be very beautiful
but that's just because i'm a beautiful
person
it's a great attitude
it's a good one to have got me far
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
i would have started sex work sooner i'm
not even gonna lie if i started when i
was like 18
i probably
would be a lot more advanced
than where i'm at now even though i've
been doing it for seven years obviously
i've made up some time
you see sex work is
your view of it is that it's been very
good to you yeah because when you make
the money you can either
because i never had money so
when i had the opportunity to have money
i invested it in myself
versus other people who just like
go shopping go on trips all the time
like
i really wanted to work on myself
because i never had that opportunity how
big a part
did your
childhood where you guys are your family
was poor
play a part in you taking this direction
where you can make really solid money
a lot
when you watch your family have nothing
or constantly
just like have to sell things or be down
because they don't have money and
they're too prideful to admit and ask
for help
it just
i don't know i know i never wanted to
end up like that i never wanted to end
up relying on anyone else to
fix my problems
are you lonely
sometimes
i would say the more deeper i got
involved in online sex work i became
extremely lonely but i kind of took a
step back from that and when i just
dance
i have the opportunity to be around
people with similar views
and i get to take more time for myself
because online sex work is so
much more difficult
than
people would imagine
what advice would you give to a girl
who's considering doing some of these
career choices you've taken off
i would just say
be honest with yourself
be honest with yourself
take care of yourself and treat yourself
the way you want others to treat you
don't make friends in the strip club i
got very lucky and that was over years
of developing relationships
but people will put you in really bad
situations when you put your trust in
the wrong people
go to work make your money stay out of
the [ __ ] and live your life and
treat it like a job i feel like a lot of
people get wrapped up
with being at the club every day
that they don't that's their center
point of life is going to the club
getting drunk with their friends
doing their little blow bag in the
bathroom and then
you know
leaving and doing it all over again the
next day you have it's not that you have
to have an end game but you have to set
yourself up for the life you want to
live
and you have to be very
on top of that or you will get lost it
is very easy to get lost
do you use alcohol or drugs or anything
to get in the mood to uh
um i used to a lot of the time i noticed
now recently that i've gotten older and
i kind of just like i have to dumb
myself down a little bit to relate to
people because i am super educated
nobody likes to know it all at the club
so i
have like a couple drinks and that's
about it i used to use drugs like my
first night stripping oh i don't
remember my first stage set i was so
[ __ ] off on xanax
so it's like
i don't know if you have to do it
but if you don't try not because i know
a bunch of brilliant people who can do
it sober and it you can
you wanna have kids
i don't think i can
really
i was pregnant one time
and i the one and only time i had an
ectopic pregnancy
and it was just very scary for me and i
don't
think having my own children is for me
but i would i love kids if i could i
probably would but also
i'm getting older you have to set
yourself up for that that's something
you have to well hopefully plan for i
know people just be willy-nilly and get
married at 20 and having children and
then they end up divorced and all that
bad [ __ ] like it's something you really
have to think about and i know with the
direction i took i don't really think i
can adopt kids
or foster just because sex work people
are like no
but i probably
i don't know if i could in my older
years i would want to open or just find
a home
and
you know maybe be like a peer
counselor or something like that
because yeah
i don't know i love kids
jade what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned
in life
in life or
in the seven years of doing sex work
either one the most important lesson
i've learned
everyone doesn't have your best
intention you know
so many different people yeah
i don't know
it's
make your money and go home
that's it that's the number one lesson
keep yourself
keep your inner self protected everyone
does not have your best interest and
people if you show them the slightest
sign
of vulnerability they will take it and
they will hold on to it
and you can end up in some super bad
situations
every man for himself
yeah literally well you're an
independent contractor so it's like
take that and run with it you are your
own business and you should run it that
way
and you're saving money
yeah you have to you have to a lot of
girls don't because like i i also know
myself and i am bipolar and i do get
depressed and i do have to dip into my
savings because you know getting
assaulted at work is a thing
and bad things do happen in those types
of places so if i
need to take a month off because i'm so
depressive i need to have something to
fall back on you can expect to make a
thousand dollars every day not even 500
and that's something
people forget
it's not always going to be there you
could tell me about being bipolar
um
what about it you know what i mean how
does it manifest itself
i don't even notice well now i do since
i'm super aware but
it's like i'm bipolar one so my episodes
are really long it's not like i'm just
like up down up down it's like
you're peaking right now you're very
manic everything's going great you have
so much energy life is making so much
money i'm so happy and outgoing
and then it's like
i can't get out of bed i'm crying every
day or i feel no emotion
and i'm like i don't want to talk to
anyone and i isolate
and that's
my two
moods
and so i used to be on medication but i
don't
for me i don't really like it
so i that's why i choose talk therapy
because it keeps me in check and it
keeps me in line and you have to do
things like journal every day you just
have to be super self-aware if you're
gonna be mentally ill
okay like
or you're gonna end up like i've been in
the psych ward i put myself in there i
was like what the [ __ ] is wrong with me
because nobody
nobody's gonna figure you out for you
that's your own personal responsibility
so i don't know being bipolar can be
scary self-harm things like that
um
but just getting older and like
acknowledging it i'm more comfortable
and confident with being bipolar
all right jay thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
best of luck to you thanks thanks
you